JJ BEHRENS: Hi.
I'm JJ Behrens.
JOE FERNANDEZ: And I'm
Joe Fernandez.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm an engineer
on the DART team.
JOE FERNANDEZ: And I'm an
engineer on the Android team.
JJ BEHRENS: So when we're not at
work, we're just a bunch of
normal guys.
JOE FERNANDEZ: Exactly.
We like to do things
normal guys do.
Like, I like to fix things
around the house.
JJ BEHRENS: I have a
house full of kids.
JOE FERNANDEZ: It's true.
JJ BEHRENS: So when Joe needed
to water his lawn, he did what
any sensible engineer
would do.
JOE FERNANDEZ: Exactly.
I'd build something.
JJ BEHRENS: You start with
an Arduino board.
JOE FERNANDEZ: Right.
And I wanted it hooked up to my
phone, so I had to write an
Android App.
JJ BEHRENS: You throw in a
little bit of Python and
Google App Engine.
JOE FERNANDEZ: And we wanted
to make watering the lawn a
little bit more fun.
So we added just a little
extra twist as well.
JJ BEHRENS: I wanted to show
that DART could be used for
real world apps.
JOE FERNANDEZ: It's true.
And we really do have a
real world app that
actually waters my lawn.
JJ BEHRENS: So let's
show you Irrduino.
JOE FERNANDEZ: And so let's
introduce you to
the Irrduino system.
It's based on open
source hardware.
The core board on it is the
Android Development Kit, which
is actually an Arduino Mega
Board with a little bit of
extra stuff on it.
I also added the Ethernet
board on top of this.
This lets me hook it up
to my home network.
So I can send RESTful web
commands to it and control my
sprinklers through
that system.
The electronics involve
the relay systems.
So these relays actually connect
to the higher power
circuits that control
the valves.
These are wired into my actual
sprinkler system, which still
works, by the way.
It lets me turn on the valves
on and off for a specific
amount of time.
I don't actually use this
that much anymore.
Because now I can actually
control this
stuff from my phone.
I've got a specific app that's
called an Irrduino sprinkler
controller.
And this lets me send those
web commands that I talked
about to actually turn
on the sprinklers
from anywhere I want.
I can be at work.
I can be on vacation.
I could be in the back of my
yard in the exact place where
I won't get wet when I
actually turn on the
sprinklers.
So here's a real quick
demonstration of the app
running on my Galaxy
Nexus phone.
This is a standard app.
There is nothing specific
to my project about it.
All I have to do is set a
specific time that I want a
sprinkler to run and then push
a button to actually run that
set of sprinklers.
This uses asynchronous tasks to
send the internet commands.
And it's all interrupt driven,
so I can turn it off at any
time or interrupt it and tell
it-- oh, actually I want the
other side of the lawn
to be watered.
And if I like, I can just shut
the whole thing down.
OK.
So let me give you a quick
demonstration of
the Irrduino system.
I've got my phone app-- my
Irrduino app-- running here.
Inside the garage the control
is actually hooked up to the
valves on the sprinkler
system.
And all I have to do to turn it
on is just push a button.
[SPRINKLER SOUNDS]
So what's happening is I'm
sending a REST web command
from my phone through
the internet cloud.
And it's hitting my controller
in the garage here.
And it's activating the
solenoids to turn on the
valves and throw water
on my lawn.
And I can actually turn
it off too by just
pushing another button.
JJ BEHRENS: Aside from an
Android application, we also
built in a web application
to control Irrduino.
This is based on Python
and Google App Engine.
You can select a particular zone
and water it for a set
number of minutes.
You could also get system status
or turn off everything.
The Log tab gives you a list
of all the recent sprinkler
runs executed by the Irrduino
controller.
The Reports tab has
two reports.
The first shows the number of
gallons used in each watering
zone per day.
The second report shows
daily watering
cost across all zones.
So we could see a dollar
amount per day.
The About tab contains what
you might expect it to
contain, along with one
little surprise.
Rather than build another social
game, I decided to
build an application that would
have a more profound
impact on the world.
This is a DART application
that actually
waters Joe's lawn.
If I click on the lawn, the
Droid will fly over and
actually water the lawn for
a short amount of time.
You could click on multiple
spots on the lawn, and it will
cue up the jobs.
I sure hope there aren't
any kids out front.
So thanks for checking
out Irrduino with us.
JOE FERNANDEZ: If you're
interested in the source code,
check out bit.ly/waterjoeslawn.